8 Milliarden
beträgt die Menschheit seit November
2022 der 8 milliardenste Mensch wurde
wurde geboren wenn man das vergleicht
mit den 50er Jahren das sind mehr als
doppelt so viele und es geht jetzt zu
diesem Thema nicht nur den allgemeinen
Bevölkerungszuwachs weltweit der ja seit
den 90er Jahren schon gebremst wird ja
die Zuwachsraten gehen zurück es wird
wahrscheinlich auf 10 10,5 Milliarden
Ende des Jahrhunderts hinauslaufen aber
es gibt ein singuläres Phänomen in
diesem Jahrhundert und das ist dass der
allergrößte Teil des Bevölkerungszuwachs
ist zwar im 21 Jahrhundert in subsahara
Afrika also in Afrika südlich der Sahara
stattfinden wird dort verdoppelt sich
die Bevölkerung von 2020 bis 20150 um
gut eine Milliarde und verdoppelt sich
ein weiteres Mal in der zweiten
Jahrhundert Hälfte also bis zum Jahr
2100 auf dann 4 Milliarden im 22
jahrhundert wird irgendwann zuerst jeder
dritte und dann jeder zweite Mensch
südlich der Sahara geboren sein
dreiviertel aller
Neugeborenen in diesem Jahrhundert
kommen südlich der Sahara zur Welt und
gleichzeitig und das ist der zweite Sinn
und das zweite singuläre Phänomen laufen
wir mit der Erderwärmung in eine
Situation hinein in der vor allem die
tropischen Gebiete also die Gebiete
zwischen den Wendekreisen fünf Grad
nördliche fünf Grad südliche breit und
da liegen 85% der afrikanischen
Landmasse in denen die Nahrungsmittel
und die Wasserfall die Situation der
Nahrungsmittelversorgung und
Wasserversorgung doch in diesen Tropen
auch noch in Südamerika massiv
beeinträchtigt werden wird wir werden
aus diesem Gründen einem enormen
Wanderungsdruck aus Afrika Richtung es
geht nur Richtung Norden ja ausgesetzt
sein und unsere Politik und im weitesten
Sinne auch die Wissenschaft die
öffentliche Diskussion nimmt diese
singulären Veränderungen
überhaupt noch nicht zur Kenntnis was
werden diese Veränderungen bewirken
zeichnen Sie uns das einmal auf wir
haben zurzeit praktisch oder sehr wenig
migrationzuwanderung aus Gebieten
südlich der Sahara also die Migration
über die wir heute reden das ist im
Wesentlichen Nordafrika das ist im
wesentlichen in der Nahe Osten also der
arabische Raum ja Afghanistan Iran
südlich der Sahara die die das sind 10
20% der Migranten ja wir reden also ich
rede hier also praktisch von wesentlich
von der zweiten Jahrhundert Hälfte aber
das beginnt natürlich schon in den 30er
40er Jahren wenn die Situation der
Nahrungsmittel Versorgung durch die
zunehmende Erwärmung so steigen wird
wenn wir wir müssen davon ausgehen dass
wir nicht nur die 1,5 Grad nicht
schaffen wir werden auch die zwei Grad
nicht scheiße ja also wir müssen dann
nackt und ehrlich machen das ist der
erste Fehler den wir begehen und wir
müssen uns darauf einstellen dass wir
einfach aus diesem hinzukommenden
Milliarden hunderten Millionen ja einen
Migrationsdruck haben den wir in Weste
aber nicht standhalten können ja wenn
ich standhalten werden das bedeutet
unsere Gesellschaft wird erst recht wenn
nach der Jahrhundertmitte die
geburtenstarken Jahrgänge dann gänzlich
weggestorben sind unsere Gesellschaft
wird in der zweiten Jahrhundert Hälfte
und das ist 30 Jahre hin ja das ist
nicht viel wird vollkommen anders
aussehen wird ökonomisch anders
strukturiert sein und es ist höchste
Zeit ob man das will oder nicht sich
damit auseinanderzusetzen dass man die
Dinge einfach mal aufs Tape bringt und
das meinte ich mit ihm wir gehen immer
noch davon aus irgendwie wird der Status
Quo auch noch in diesem Jahrhundert so
sein wie wir ihn aus den letzten 50
Jahren kennen Riesenfehler
das wäre natürlich ganz vielen Menschen
auch einfach lieb Frau hermelder sind
wir dieser Entwicklung völlig machtlos
ausgeliefert wir verdrängen das einfach
ich habe zwei 15 auch mal ein Buch
geschrieben die Zukunft wird anders
klingt nach machtlos ausgeliefert werden
ich kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen was
ich hier vortragen finde das auch
richtig dass wir es aussprechen und die
Frage steht im Raum ergibt man sich
jetzt einfach oder überlegt man ob
bisherige Handlungen nicht gewirkt haben
also ich habe z.B im Bundeshaushalt bei
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit war ich
jahrelang mit beschäftigt meiner Meinung
nach festgestellt dass da sehr viel Geld
für wenig Effekt ausgegeben wird das
hatte sozusagen wenig Effekt im Sinne
was erreicht werden soll nämlich das
andere Länder wirtschaftlich vorankommen
und ihre Bevölkerung versorgen können
weil die hohe Geburtenrate mitunter auch
historisch damit was zu tun hat dass die
Eltern dann irgendjemanden brauchen der
sie versorgt und nicht alle Kinder
durchkommen bis zum Erwachsenenalter
meiner Meinung nach wäre es zum Beispiel
klug wenn die Europäer endlich mal
verstanden haben dass sie sozusagen ein
bisschen für Afrika mit zuständig sind
was ich glaube dass das stimmt die
Amerikaner haben da Südamerika also in
der Entwicklungshilfe ja woanders ich
würde sagen eine wirtschaftlich
Zusammenarbeit die darauf beruht dass
ich Partnerländer bilden und dass man
versucht eine Industrialisierung in
diesen Ländern zu erreichen damit ihre
Bevölkerung organisieren kann und
versorgen kann und da im Gegenzug zu
verhandeln dass man zum Beispiel auf
eine zwei-kind-politik oder sowas
umschwenkt um die ganz große Spitze in
der zweiten Jahrhundert Hälfte ein
bisschen abzuflen ich halte das für
schlau aber dann müssten wir uns
wirklich auch so einigen da müsst nicht
Europa und Afrika in den Tisch setzen
und das klären haben wir in den letzten
50 Jahren alles falsch gemacht Frau
Gaschke ist unsere Entwicklungspolitik
im Prinzip gescheitert unsere
Entwicklungshilfe ja ich glaube es gibt
von von Peter den Satz die einzige
Katastrophe die jeder versteht ist die
Katastrophe die keiner überlebt und sie
neigen einfach das ist aber glaube ich
auch normal menschlich ist dazu also
etwas fernliegendere Probleme zu
verdrängen ja auch wichtig ist fürs
Überleben fürs leben und überleben weil
wenn ich sozusagen jetzt Szenario höre
dann ist das ja Apokalypse pur nein also
da kann man nicht entfernen
30 Jahren also sozusagen das natürlich
also sozusagen man kann mal bei der
Entwicklung Zusammenarbeit anfangen ich
glaube alles was da im Moment zum
Fenster rausgeschmissen wird ist
vollkommen sinnlose Projekte also die
Demokratisierung der afghanischen
Gesellschaft jetzt von Dubai aus mit
irgendwelchen
medienprogrammen
einen wahnsinnigen Migrationsdruck
kriegen und zwar genau ja auch wegen der
Klima Probleme wenn wir die
Industrialisierung vorantreiben mit
diesen Menschenmassen dann treiben
natürlich wiederum darf
zu dem Thema wenn wir die Hälfte des
Geld ist ausgeben würden was wir
ausgeben wollen sie CO2 Vermeidung und
geben es diesen Ländern damit die anders
anfangen in der Energieproduktion haben
wir mehr CO2 eingespart als wir
Deutschen noch rausquetschen können also
hier reinkommen
müsste kolonialistischer erlauben sich
so zu entwickeln wie wir es gemacht
Verträge schließt ist das nicht ja aber
dann kommen die und sagen hey wieso
jetzt habt ihr 60 Jahre lang gegangen
die wollten gerne dass die dass die
industrialisierten Länder ihn dabei
helfen das ist ein Fünkchen in unserem
industrialisierten Luxusleben und sagen
dann ist alles und jetzt hat uns der
Messias Greta Thunberg wer auch immer
erleuchtet und jetzt haben wir
verstanden es ist falsch und deswegen
ihr armen Afrikaner so zu haben bitte
lasst es jetzt und wir bezahlen eine
Welt Gedanke den die Afrikaner aber man
muss kontrollieren nicht also wenn wenn
dann die geldstiftung das versucht also
müssen
ja mit anderen Methoden klar aber
sozusagen ja auch Problem sozusagen
kennenzulernen
in Thailand und dann anderen
das hat natürlich damit zu tun dass wir
in Asien seit 40 50 Jahren eine
ökonomisches wachstumszenario haben
real,-
weniger als 2% zur gesamten
Weltwirtschaft Welt
Wertschöpfung war ja das sind extrem
geringe Zahlen der das gesamte
Stromverbrauch energieverbrauchen als
Stromverbrauch in Afrika ist geringer
als der von Algerien oder von Spanien ja
da ist in Afrika ist insofern ein
faszinierendes Szenario weil sie
gleichzeitig
archaische Zustände und enormen
Fortschritt enorme Entwicklung haben und
ich möchte mir ganz klar für mich ist
das kein apokalyptisches Szenario wir
werden eine gemeinsame Zukunft als
Europäer und Afrikaner haben die wir
noch nie so gehabt haben das ist doch
kein keine Apokalypse mehr sehen
ja das ist das Problem ja
anders als heute und das Entscheidende
ist das es geht ja auch unsere Kinder an
zwei Dinge diese
Gesellschaft integriert kriegen ja und
und wir werden wir werden uns von den
Vorstellungen dieser Gesellschaft auch
entfernen müssen und das glaube ich jede
neue Generation die jetzt da
hineinwächst die wächst ja schon in eine
andere Welt hinein das sind ja die
Generationen die jetzt richtig aus den
20 Jahrhundert kommen die sagen nein das
ist für mich ein apokalyptischer Gedanke
weil diese Vorstellung des 20
Jahrhundert die ist zu Ende und die
Zukunft ist auch nur für die die
loslassen können darum geht's mir also
ich will nur 20 Jahre alt
wir müssen loslassen können und das
darum geht wir müssen dafür werden dass
man loslassen
ja
und das ist genau
multikultierte haben uns eine riesen
Mauer wir können keine riesen wir werden
keine riesenmauer bauen können aber
indem wir den Menschen indem wir heute
auch uns selbst sagen und klar machen
was auf uns zukommt werden wir auch
unterschiedlich je nach Individuum
reagieren ich bin sicher nehmen Sie mal
so Roman von Michelle Weg das ist
natürlich jetzt romanhafte
in Roman hat verklärt verzerrt ja aber
doch gibt es auch Europäer Utopien
die die mit dem die unter den neuen
unter diesen extrem multikulturellen
Unterwerfung Leben andere ziehen weg ähm
wir werden auch so eine Domino
Entwicklung haben wie wie sie immer bei
allen Wanderungsbewegungen war die
Einkommen rein dann wandern dann wandern
auch bestimmte heraus ja wer sagt dass
wir nicht in der zweiten Jahrhundert
Hälfte Wanderungsbewegung von Europa
nach Osten haben zum Beispiel auf jeden
Fall ein positiveres Bild muss man sagen
trotzdem ihr neues Buch heißt das
unheimliche ja 100 für uns alle noch
einmal zeigen